what are the the biggest mistakes you
see people make on like in the early
stages of the entrepreneurial Journey
so I mean our hourly rates we've talked
about
um comparisonitis like the moment you
can pay yourself to other people like
again
um you things start to creep in like
imposter syndrome you start to
self-doubt you start to
um one of the things you mentioned oh
you know there's people out there and
they're doing it they're absolutely
killing it off so why me
um but that's actually going to stop you
from starting anything like you if if
you don't even uh what was the famous
quote you miss 100 of the shots you
don't take because I can't remember who
that was by but
um it's that sort of philosophy so the
best thing you do everybody has
something unique to offer
um like think about it you know there's
hundreds of thousands of business books
out there so why should I write another
business book well it's because it's
it's me it's Unique you're writing a
book you know there's going to be
something unique in that that book you
know that only you're able to kind of
convey your message in your own unique
way
um so comparisonitis is like the death
of most entrepreneurs
um and it's I get it it's it's quite
hard you know to face up to the fact
that there's going to be challenges and
potential failures knockbacks it's going
to be hard work and things like that but
um let's let's not like stop before
we've even got started basically
one thing that people struggle with is
yeah just to this point you know oh you
know why would anyone sign up to my
relationship coaching business there are
other relationship coaches out there
with more experience who are charging
less or maybe charging more but whatever
that thing might be
um and if I were starting this
relationship business from scratch I
would be feeling a lot of imposter
syndrome yeah because I'd be like
yeah I don't have all the clients that
these people have so how might I
approach that if I were thinking about
it how much do you want it to work
a lot a lot like 100 I'm all in like
let's I'm just gonna go for it anyway I
know that I know that these things are
there these challenges these worries are
there and they're real
but can I see myself just working
through that I guess the fear that would
hold me back is this thing of what if it
doesn't work okay imagine in 12 months
time it's worked
well yeah then my life would have
changed okay and what but in 12 months
time what does that business look like
what's giving you the confidence to for
it to have worked
if I can land even five clients five
clients okay so there we go so five
clients well what's what's the route
five clients just our first client okay
so there's these little
um they're they're called okrs
objectives and key results right
um amazing book so I'm it's like a
library recommendation
measure what matters absolutely
um objectives and key results that's
what okr stands for and the idea is that
you have one overarching objective and
then there's a series of key results
which kind of lead you they give you
little signals that we know we're on
track to achieve achieve our objective
so if you if your goal is to have a
successful you know dating coaching
business
um which is making 25k a year and it's
got 10 clients in it well step number
one is a client
step number 0.5 is to go and have one of
those first five conversations chats
that we talked about
I should have started with step three
step number naught Point naught one is
like to go and put yourself forward to
go and do one of the talks so it's like
there's these little steps you know that
you're kind of on track so reminding
yourself
um about the the smallest First Step uh
the second thing is also it's I call it
the truths exercises reminding yourself
what you know to be true about you so
Ali and this is this is really hard as
an exercise but
um list off 10 things that you know are
true about you right now yeah right now
okay 10 Things I know are true about me
yeah are we talking I mean like anything
life business doesn't matter yeah I'm
five foot eleven and a half but I go by
six foot one on hinge obviously
um
I enjoy playing video games so I don't
make much time for it I enjoy reading
books I have a YouTube channel I uh have
a podcast I
went to medical school I vaguely enjoyed
working as a doctor
I uh used to play chess and would like
to get more into it I like playing the
guitar I love musical theater and Ed
Sheeran and Taylor Swift
um I'd like to release an album of songs
one day
cool I think that's about 10. yeah at
least uh and you could probably come up
with 100 different things a thousand
different things which you know to be
true about you and the thing is nobody
can take those away you own those things
they are like truths about you right
um and so alongside that there was a
journey the makeup of you made those
truths happen
um in 12 months time what do you want to
be true about you I'd like to be a
published author
um I'd like to have written a book I'm
proud of I'd like to have shored up the
foundations of the business I'd like to
have lived in Austin for a bit you know
a few things like that okay so one one
little tweak to that is the language
which you used so you said I'm going to
I'm going to So when you say I'm going
to it kind of gives you permission to
kind of put it off into the future okay
so when you're creating future truths
you have to treat them like they've
already happened to call so you just
change the language that I have I am
cool yeah I'm a published author
um I have lived in Austin for a few
months
um I've written a book I'm proud of I am
I am currently working on my second book
uh I have built my business in uh sort
of central operationally effective way
Etc yeah there you go so that that's
Ali's identity in 12 months time that's
that's who you are okay
um I encourage everybody to I call it my
morning formula although ironically I
only ever read it in the afternoon when
I have a break my afternoon break
um but literally I have a list of like
100 truths all those things both future
ones and except pre-existing ones I know
are true about me whenever I have that
element that moment of self-doubt I go
back to that and I look at the Legacy
which I built up and I look at who I am
as in my makeup my identity everything
um and it makes me feel good
am I more or less likely to do stuff
when I feel good more likely to do more
likely yeah yeah you're going to see
those challenges that you might see as
challenges they're going to be just
you're just going to have taken the edge
off it by just giving yourself a little
boost of self-confidence and self-worth
because these things are true